is that that's a steak oh my god it's
medium rare
the internal temperature is medium rare
last week i received what is probably
the pinnacle of toaster technology the
precipice the peak
the best toaster money can really buy
this is
the revolution toaster from revolution
cooking it's a smart
toaster it's got a touch screen where
you can select
what you want to toast and how much you
want it toasted
and best of all as many of you pointed
out in the comments of my last video
no more jump scares because it smoothly
elevates your toast when it's done
the only catch is at 300 which
is a lot of money to spend on a toaster
so i wanted to see how compared to
a more humble toaster so i went on
amazon i found the top reviewed toaster
and
i bought it this is the bread king
toaster it comes in at just under 30
and it has thousands of five star
reviews
it's also about as standard as a toaster
gets
so today i'm going to be toasting a
bunch of toastable items to see if this
300
toaster is really worth your money or
just
your aw at looking at the shininess of
it that's really
what i do most of the time you can just
catch me standing in the kitchen leaning
over the counter
batting my eyelashes at it am i
attracted to a toaster
no
[Music]
to make this a bit more scientific in
addition to my own opinions i've
enlisted the help of my roommate will
who will be doing a blind taste test of
everything i toast today
so without further ado let's toast
cheers
get it toast
[Music]
bread it's fresh a little over medium
toasted
how many settings are there there are
six settings i think the hardest thing
about this is gonna be comparing
actually what the settings on this dial
are
to the brownness on this thing but i'm
just gonna put this on four
and start
the smart toaster has a countdown timer
on it so i know
how long it's gonna take this is really
gonna be a surprise
oh it's done ouch oh
and that's done shortly after so this is
the toast out of the smart toaster and
this is the toast out of the regular
toaster
one the regular toaster cuts off a bit
before the top whereas the
smart toaster goes almost all the way up
this how does it taste
because to be honest i can't see why
there would be a difference
sure is toast all right let's try the
other one now
there is not much difference i want to
say the flavor of the bread is retained
a little more in this but that could
just
entirely be a placebo effect if i had to
pick one
i would pick the revolution
this one's crunchier on the bottom i
would pick this one because the bottom
of this one
is too crunchy and the top isn't all
that crunchy like it feels one-sided
i really don't taste enough of a
difference to make
an informed decision
[Music]
oh it's me so these are mostly frozen
i'm gonna see how these two toasters
cook
from frozen waffle
frozen let's go with medium start
they both get very hot very fast this
toaster just in the middle of the cycle
turned all the heating elements off for
a second and then i think
turned them on again there's definitely
some like
cooking pattern going on in here that's
not just
heat up food toast in the waffle
and it's done they both kind of got
mushed at the bottom the cooking on both
of them is
pretty similar even though these look
very similar in how much they were
cooked
this one feels a little undercooked i do
think this did a little bit better but
not ten times better
i'm gonna try the left one first
it feels pretty evenly cooked this one
feels much more cooked
much more solid this side of the waffle
is like too hot to touch
and this side of the waffle is fine i
crunch on this one more it's not
overdone this one i think is overdone
this one looks more overdone but it's
not what the [ __ ]
[Music]
has oh that's not done so the difference
between a little over three and
four is like cutting the cooking time in
half that doesn't make
any sense
wow so let's taste test the english
muffins or as they call them in england
muffins oh this toaster
looks on the surface like it completely
cooked this english muffin but the
crunch
on this one was more pronounced so i
don't know what's happening
this one actually is better i want to
say
i'm gonna eat the right one first oh
that's a hot english muffin
yeah this one tastes overdone i don't
know if it's to do with the way it was
toasted
but this one is the one that i would
want to eat more often but we've toasted
all these normal things
that you put in a toaster i want to see
how these toasters do against something
else
oh no how's the steak dinner sound to
you
this is a very cheap steak it's like a
steak had a child with a burger
do you imagine it rejected it steak
please remove steak oh yeah
i didn't even consider that come with it
that's not done
this is not done all right that's
definitely a bit done
oops oh what happened it didn't jump
it's definitely cooking
and putting it back in that doesn't look
raw at all anymore
yeah that looks like a steak that's a
steak oh my god
it's medium rare the internal
temperature is medium rare
scary oh my gosh
all right let's cut these open let's see
how they taste i wouldn't say this one's
well done but it's definitely medium and
this is definitely a bit more medium
rare
yeah all right do we eat it let's try it
yeah
it's still disgusting it's not good i
didn't do a really bad
stick i kind of want to try a nice steak
in the toaster
like marinate it i definitely don't
think the toasters let us down
i think i think the choice of steak let
us down more than the toasters
i just for sure i should have bought a
more expensive steak
i mean there's always next time overall
i would say there's not a huge
difference between these two toasters
i really think that i wouldn't call out
the fact that they were made with
different toasters yeah
with this one the main thing you're
getting is predictability in terms of
how your toast is gonna come out
this does cook toast a little faster and
i think overall
the toast is more evenly cooked but not
ten times
faster and ten times more easy to cook
links to both of these toasters will be
down in the description below
this toaster while it's overkill it's
probably the best toaster money can buy
if you want to save a few bucks this is
honestly a very good toaster it did the
job
this one wins the award for best toaster
this one wins the award for most
toaster for the money yeah